when you got freaky with your lady well
way back in the days you not put cheese
on the nip no no you told me you did
it's incompetent
[Laughter]
[Music]
kevin could roast wayne better than
dwayne could roast kevin one
two three no i'm gonna disagree i'm
gonna strong
your impression of me is pretty goddamn
good
hey what's up man okay cool
all right what we got here
what we got here okay we gotta
overcharge the shop we gotta shout right
here okay hey
boss man
hey make sure you give me a thing
[Laughter]
that's it
[Laughter]
no but wait a second no
no i do a decent one you do i got a good
one i gotta get it
first of all
big announcement
a big announcement okay it's in my feet
first of all you not me but you have
helped me this thing because of you we
are in thailand in thailand in the
anti-arctic area we just reached the
number one
of all time the global plan but it's not
it's you
hey get in there hey listen hardest
workers in the room start with
okay okay in 2016 people magazine were
right to vote playing the sexiest
i've never seen a bigger piece of but as
a matter of fact i should throw this
water all over the guy
strongly never seen why are you so angry
i mean
dj i've never been more upset in my life
not not not
at the fact that you won
at the fact that i wasn't even
considered in that year that was one of
my sexiest years uh i'm just putting out
here dj that was one of my sexiest years
i there's a lot of shirt off play that
year it was a lot i i've really i really
strategically put myself in position to
be in a run and i just felt like i don't
know i just feel like it was a setup it
was a hoax i wasn't even in a running
which is [ __ ] you were in the
running no no i wasn't dj you were i
gotta see it then i see the picture of
you in the pool acting like
what's white what ugly
face is that acting like you're not
looking at the camera
what is that
i could have did way better than that
i got too many poses
there's still hope you got to keep hope
alive i'm trying i'm gonna try i'm gonna
go at it again this year buddy
being too short is better than being too
tall
one
two
yeah yeah yeah
strongly agree there's not a pair a
pants or a shirt that i can't find in my
size i mean talking about talking about
anything women's sneakers if i like them
i'll just get a bigger size they're
available for me uh some some women's
pants i'm not afraid to admit it i've
been in them uh you know they just
they've just been a better fit for me i
got little hips uh i mean i can go down
the line here of why why this is better
for me i mean yeah closer us over here
baby yeah well you thought i'd go here
yeah but i went here okay why did you
why did you strongly agree i strongly
agreed with you but then i thought well
maybe i i just agree because you
strongly agreed oh so i wanted to keep
it in the same agreement family because
i'm your friend okay but i want to get
back to something okay you were in
women's pants well i mean we don't have
to get into it they said it well it was
a pair of pants that could have been
quote unquote unisex i didn't find out
later until later that they weren't
actually my stylist didn't tell me uh
she just put me in them and i was like
man these jeans are nice wow she was
like well they're they're a petite fit
first of all i'm confident with whatever
i do
i'm just saying it was a shock to know
that i was in a pair of women's how did
they feel though how did they what did
they feel to be honest with you dj made
my ass feel amazing uh like i told you
my hips are different so it's a
different whatever we don't need to get
let's go to the next let's go to the
next one dwayne the rob johnson would be
a brilliant
u.s president
three
oh wow yeah
i said it ma'am i said it because i want
to see the crashing burn
so you want to get me in the white house
just so i can crash and burst just so
you can stress yourself out jesus
i want to see i just want to see you do
this 13 times
i'm so sick of these people i think he
is more than capable of doing whatever
he puts his mind to that's why i'm over
on that side wow thank you thank you
very much thank you you thought i would
be an [ __ ] well look well i i said
disagree because i feel that just
because i have a few leadership
qualities doesn't make me necessarily a
good presidential candidate i love i
love that you are thinking like that but
i'm just saying you are a put your mind
to something to accomplish god i
personally would give you a call before
you start to do like hey man you sure
you want to do this
it's been it's been good man you don't
have a girlfriend good run good you
don't got to do this man you chose to do
it like all right life is good yes yes
pineapple on pizza is disgusting
one
two
three
i can't believe he said come on it's
amazing it's disgusting
no
listen
pineapple mixed with ham or mixed with
bacon on pizzas
oh my god why don't you just give me a
bucket now so i can barf it
oh what don't you like about it what do
you mean what do i like about it uh
pineapple is a fruit it's a fruit that
should be eaten by themselves i'm sorry
what is it all of a sudden there's rules
to put on yes on pizza i didn't know
that you could mix pineapple with cheese
and enjoy it that's disgusting okay well
what do you like on your pizza uh how
about just some cheese just cheese and
little tomato and some red sauce that's
it yes that's it no i don't want
anything else on it it's called a
hawaiian oh oh i get it i see what's
happening oh god
that's right no it's bad when you got
freaky with your lady well way back in
the days you not put cheese on the
nipples no no you told me you did it's
incompetent
a flight would be the best super power
to have
one
two
three i don't know i disagree
i disagree me too yeah what kind of
super power would you like to have i
want i want to be able to hold my
i don't want to [ __ ] anymore
like hold it in yeah i don't want to be
able to anymore oh so just no more no
[ __ ] comes out i'm not even holding it's
just no more no more but that's my power
if i chose to right i could but my power
is saying i don't want you today
i'll shut it off so if i i could eat all
day right and on that day if i feel like
going i'll go but i'm like not today
that's my power
wow yeah
i want command boom whoa come on yeah
that's it i want x-ray vision where i
could see through
oh
oh
wait a second
it's got that's a little dark buddy no
just see-through i just want to see
through things
you know like when you look out you see
a sea of people yeah i see that actually
what are you trying to see specifically
just you
know just like they're inside people's
heart souls
how do we get in trouble kevin hart
would be incredible in the wwe
one
two three
boom
yes
yes
i already know what i would do go tell
them uh okay first of all my man my my
guy that i would create uh nobody's ever
really incorporated food into like
wrestling and my whole thing would be
peanut butter oh like yeah you hey hey
hey
you want things to get a little nutty
butter yeah that would be my turn
oh god here comes kevin hart he's
he's going in his shorts
nutty butter all over their face and
what what's a finishing move i didn't
think that through i thought the nutty
butter would take you out no if it
didn't if it did there's a bunch of
wrestlers yeah so they'll be they'll
like the peanut butter they would lick
it well then that's what i would give
them the i would give them the handy the
handy i would
right and i would come across like i lay
the smackdown kind of thing well or
i would give them the poke of death
oh yeah where would you poke them and
the forehead like a like take this
well but
my fingers have been all over the world
oh
oh yeah oh now stop boom let me create
this hypothetical scenario you and brock
lesnar oh i want some you want something
i want some of that you want something
he's six three he's you know 280 pounds
sounds like lunch beast yeah that's
lunch sounds like how would you how
would you beat that ass hey brock aka my
it's time for you to get a little thing
called the poke
come on man
i'm here come on man i'm in oh let me
tell you something
i don't tell you why i want brock he's
got nothing on me he's a vegetable a
piece of broccoli i'll snap him in half
and throw the piece i don't want away
it's gonna sound like a little bit of
cocoa
cocoa beware one of the best wrestlers
of all
[Music]
time i like american football i just
will never forget
very dangerous why it's called football
because they don't use their feet i just
don't understand why it's called
football yeah it should be causally
different maybe throw ball whatever you
want to call it